the loud house quickly became one of the
most popular animated series of all
times and this is why we keep watching
it so we know everything about this do
you think that you're the biggest fan of
the loud house we think we are but if
you do - you'll have to watch this video
until the end to tell us if you already
knew about all this if you love the loud
house as much as we do
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you 20 things about the loud
house you didn't know the family of
rabbits when the creator Chris Savino
pitched his idea he actually had in mind
a family of rabbits and there were not
only 10 sister rabbits there were 25 of
them Chris thought that rabbits multiply
so it was a funny joke and he also
wanted to do a funny animal show after
working on a human bass show for Disney
but someone told him that she felt like
he would have more chances if it were
about humans so he erased the ears and
the tail and adjusted the number of
sisters down from 25 to 10 this is how
everything started to fall into place
the name of siblings don't you think
it's hard to find the name of 10
siblings that start with the letter L
actually all the rabbits were all the
names and we can't believe that he found
a way to name all of them but for the
loud sisters he was lucky enough to have
a lot of L names around him his five
sisters are all L names and four letters
so they inspired Lory Lisa Lynn Louanne
and Lana he also had a wiener dog named
Lola and his mother-in-law had a dog
named Luna Lucy and Lily were two names
he wanted to give to its kids if he had
daughters and then Lenny was inspired by
the character from Of Mice and Men the
real family so we know that five sisters
were named after real-life people and we
wouldn't be surprised if Chris's nine
siblings inspired many of the things
that happened on the show so what do
they think about the loud house they
love it and they are just really
flattered that their names are
synonymous with the cartoon now Chris
said that they would send videos or
snippets of text of whatever they had
seen in the episode that they loved his
brothers even texted him to say that
they want their names to be part of the
show too so don't be surprised if you
see
Michael or Frankie the passion for
comics when he was a kid Chris loved to
read the daily newspaper and the Sunday
paper with the color funnies
there were reprints of peanuts and Pogo
around the house and he always read them
he always knew that this is what he
wanted to do he wanted to have his own
comic strip however even though he knew
that people were making cartoons he
never thought that was a job he could do
it's not until his senior year in high
school that he found out that there were
schools that taught that just wait to
see how it influenced the show the real
story it's so easy to relate to the loud
siblings that we think that Chris had to
be inspired by his own life however he
said that the show isn't really
autobiographical he just wants to find
little things that will make people say
that it happened to them as a kid this
is why he and the writers came up with
some things that happened to them in the
past even though they don't face the
whole story on this and by the way the
name of the sisters don't really match
their personas Chris just always wants
to find something that people with a lot
of siblings can relate to and that
people with no siblings can understand -
the first married gay couple for one of
the episodes of the first season
overnight success the loud house
surprised everyone with a married gay
and biracial couple Lincoln's best
friend Clyde had two dads and we have to
admit that Harold and Howard are really
cute no one cares that they are gay it's
all about the dads being way too
protective it was the first married gay
couple on Nickelodeon and we think that
it's a great idea to show a little
diversity so kids will understand that
love is love this is why most people
were really happy to meet them
unfortunately not everyone agreed with
this decision the controversy some
people think that's showing a gay couple
on television is not appropriate for
kids this is why the Christian group 1
Million Moms started alerting parents
they said that just because something
may be legal or because some are
choosing a lifestyle doesn't make it
morally correct according to them
Nickelodeon should stick to entertaining
instead of pushing an agenda they even
think that kids face danger when they
are exposed to same-sex marriage because
it forces a premature discussion on
sexual orientation that is
Wheatly uncalled for we are happy that
this group didn't really have the power
to do anything but unfortunately we
can't say the same about other countries
the ban in Kenya in 2017 can you decided
to ban six animated shows that aired on
Nickelodeon and Cartoon Network because
they thought that it was an attempt to
normalized glamorize and glorify
homosexual behavior and impair their
moral judgement on the institution of
the family let's not forget that
homosexuality is illegal in Kenya and
people can go to prison for this this is
why the loud house was banned in the
whole country along with shows like The
Legend of Korra Hey Arnold Steven
universe Adventure Time and clearance
love is not the choice but hate is and
this is why we'd rather watch our
favorite show than ban it for no good
reason the new gender Clyde's parents
are not the only queer people on the
show in Ellis for love we also found out
that Luna had a crush on a girl named
Sam which probably makes her bisexual we
were really happy for her and we hope
that we will have the chance to see
these two once again but did you know
that Sam is actually a little different
in Korea
Sam's gender has changed into a male and
she has a male voice actor people
probably think that this story would be
more appropriate if she were a boy but
we have to disagree with that the
episode that almost got banned another
episode could have been banned and this
time it was for a whole different reason
people just thought that it was
incredibly bad in no such luck
Lincoln is bad luck to everyone in the
family and this is why they all reject
him and he has even kicked out from the
house many people think that this is the
worst the loud house episode ever made
as it promotes child abuse and neglect
and even made some people cry some
people even started a petition online
but we think that 20 M people are not
enough to make Nickelodeon change the
original short the first time we met the
loud family was in an original short
featured on Nickelodeon's 2013 animated
shorts program in this short film
Lincoln simply wanted to go to the
bathroom but first he had to go through
the hallway where all his sisters were
we have already seen this before and
that's because the theme song was based
on this this is what gave Chris Savino
the chance to create his own
made a series that was quickly going to
become the most popular cartoon on
Nickelodeon in 2016 a slightly altered
version of the short premiered on Nick
comm so we can have the chance to see
how it all started
the theme song whenever we hear the
theme song of the loud house we know
that our favorite show is on TV and we
have to watch it now when he was a kid
Chris remembers that the show's gave at
least one minute to an opening title to
set up the whole show he only had 30
seconds for the loud house and he
decided to make the best out of it
he wrote a ton of lyrics and people took
some of them to create a new song that
became an earworm we can't imagine the
loud house without the theme song so we
think that it was totally worth it
this grip and the story board is the
loud house based on the script or the
storyboard chris said that the scripts
are usually 95% there and the storyboard
artists can then add some little things
but the problem with the loud house is
that without a script it would be easy
to forget many of the amazing characters
they have to think about their presence
in the house since the beginning
storyboard artists can also discover new
things when they see a really good
opportunity for a joke a line or a
reaction when a character is just
standing in the way but usually the
final result will look like the script
the comics style so we know that Chris
Savino loved comics when he was a kid
and you can clearly see it when you
watch the show for example the title of
the show looks just like a comic this is
also it makes it easier to animate the
LAT house you usually see the scene from
only one angle and the camera doesn't
move a lot unless it's really necessary
as Chris Savino said characters are
funny the camera is not he wants us to
focus only on them and this is why we
don't really minds if there are no
dramatic shots the voice actors did you
know that seven voice actors are playing
the sisters in the loud house but how is
that possible when there are 10
characters that's because some of them
are actually the voice of many sisters
the talented Grady Lyle is not only Lily
but also Lana and Lola Jessica de Cicco
also plays two really different
characters Lynn and Lucie loud grant
Palmer used to play Lincoln in the first
season but he was replaced by Colin Dean
when he grew
don't you think it's weird to play many
characters that are talking to each
other in the same scene it would
certainly be fun to see the pet names so
we know that people and dogs in the life
of Chris Savino inspired the names of
the loud sisters but did you know that
the names of the pets were inspired by
some people too they were all named
after a famous cartoonist Charles the
dog was named after Charles M Schultz
cliff the cat was inspired by cliff
starett
Gio the hamster is based on Gio McManus
and then Walt the bird is named after
Walt Kelly or Walt Disney Chris was also
inspired by his own family as he lived
with many animals when he was a kid the
colors you have probably noticed this
but each character is associated with
one color but are you able to name all
of them Lincoln is orange Laurie is
light blue Lenny is turquoise Luna is
purple Lou Ann is yellow Lynn is red
Lucy is black Lana is blue Lola is pink
Lisa is green and Lily is lavender you
can clearly see these colors in the
theme song when Lincoln is running
through the hallway and also in the
pictures on the wall we can't believe
that it was there during all this time
and so many of us didn't notice it the
rabbit if you are a fan of the loud
house you probably remember
bun-bun a stuffed rabbit that belongs to
Lincoln he can't even remember a time
where he didn't have bun bun in his life
and has panic attacks whenever he thinks
that something bad could happen to him
but this stuffed animal is also really
meaningful to the Creator you remember
when we told you that the show used to
be based on rabbits well fun bun is
modeled after Lincoln's original design
from when he was going to be a rabbit we
think that the best choice was to make
him human but it's still funny to see
this little bunny in his room the
original Lennie we also found out that
Linney's name was based on the
characters from Of Mice and Men but did
you know that she used to look just like
him - that's right
Lenny used to be an eight-year-old who
was super sweet but didn't know how
strong she was the first design looks
nothing like her she evolved and changed
but savino still wanted to show us how
development works you need to be open to
change your ideas for the better and
this is how we had the chance to fall in
love with the sweet Lenny that we all
know
the end of Chris Savino we talked about
Chris Savino a lot but did you know that
he's not a part of the loud house
anymore he was suspended and later fired
from his own show when many women
accused him of sexual harassment over
the years a Nickelodeon spokesperson
said that they take allegations of
misconduct very seriously and they are
committed to fostering a safe and
professional workplace but don't worry
the loud house will continue to air on
Nickelodeon and be in production do you
know any other secrets about the loud
house don't be shy to tell us what it is
in the comment section down below we
love to hear what you think and that's
it for 20 things about the loud house
you didn't know for more stories like
this make sure you watch five TV shows
that copy the loud house thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]